[Music]
i support the plan because i think we
need the infrastructure there's a lot to
be rebuilt
and that's important of course we really
don't know where all the dollars coming
from because there's constant fighting
on it and such but i think the plan
should go out there anyways let's get it
started let's get people back to work
let's you know pump money into the
economy and everything i'm concerned
about the national debt because it's
just massive
but i think you know we need to we're
going to be investing in infrastructure
which will create jobs
hopefully
and
as far as we just need to inject more
money and help people you know people
just don't get paid i don't think a
livable wage enough at the lower
levels
and so they need a little extra help
seems like the timing is at least wrong
we've just spent an awful lot of money
coming out of covid it seems like it'd
be better spent a little bit
down the road
[Music]
you know i think it's going to bump up
inflation
i think more money put the government's
putting into the economy is not coming
from private sectors
noticing as you guys know the grocery
store we were just at costco this
morning and it was probably you know 10
item higher than it was several months
ago gas prices going up food prices
going up we're seeing that in
housing and we're seeing that in being
able to attract the workforce food
gasoline
cars all these
things i'm looking for in
remodeling the house both labor and
materials cost quite a bit more
well what i do because my mind works
differently i fill up the car when i'm
half full so i'm only spending half as
much
but yes
that that's probably my biggest impact
yes going to the pump you know instead
of 25 it's 30 bucks you know i'm not a
high income earner so
um that does impact you kind of it kind
of kind of bleeds you dry a little bit
you know just a little prick here a
little prick there and also you're like
wow i'm spending this much more
[Music]
you know i don't know if i blame any
particular person for it but i certainly
think that uh
we need some resolution to it
i think our economy operates at near 100
capacity most of the time and it doesn't
take too much to to get it out of whack
you can't blame the one party or the
another party i mean there's a lot of
there's just so much division on capitol
hill it seems like it's difficult to get
anything done and everybody's just like
drawn a line and they're either all for
it or all against it pretty much well
i'm going to have to say the current
administration
just he's not america first uh he
doesn't care about the working class
he's worried about the academia of the
of running the united states